it's unique right
we're not anywhere near the ocean and
yet we're teaching inmates how to
commercial dive
so that they can get out and get a good
job and be productive members of society
it's a hard thing to get your mind
around at the end of the day we're
seeing guys change their lives
[Music]
my name is jeff powers i'm the lead dive
instructor at the california institution
for men the marine technology training
center is a commercial dive program run
by cal pia within the prison the dive
school was founded in 1970.
hundreds of guys have graduated from the
program since then and the lion's share
of our graduates our successes only six
percent of our guys uh come back to
prison we have guys offshore in the oil
platforms we have guys working on ships
in every port in the country our
graduates get out there and kick butt
it's simple and they they love it
the program is 18 months physical
training is a huge part of this dive
school these guys are here at seven in
the morning ready to go then they start
into their physical training routine
that usually involves lots of running
lots of calisthenics lots of swimming
everything is more of a challenge
underwater
projects have to be taken super
seriously they can be considered life or
death obviously
one of the biggest skills that dive
students got to learn is just working on
a dive station
it's founded on safety and teamwork
naturally we want our guys to be strong
but we also want our guys to be smart do
we have a pretty good grasp on dalton's
law we spend as much time as a classroom
as we do doing hands-on stuff it's very
important that my guys understand
diving physics diving physiology in
depth
we approach the learning as a team
and we don't let guys fall off
up and over i've been in prison for
about 11 years
and i have about 18 months left my
driving force for being here is
i want to be more than just
f 84 205.
that's my inmate number
i want to be more than that i want to
prove to everybody else that i'm more
than that i'm a person i made a mistake
but at least i can say that i gave it my
all here and i can step out of here and
give myself a chance i was in prison for
12 years nine months i did eight of
those years at california institution
for men and i've been out of prison for
six and a half years
i didn't have any chances left
you know um one more mistake and this
would have been my life forever
i feel every day that
the life that i have now i owe to this
program in some little way everything i
do as far as my skills even skills i've
learned since i've left here
it's all based on what i learned from
this program
[Music]
if a guide isn't given some sort of work
skills some sort of life skills then how
is he not going to go back to what he
was doing before
we give them a different chance that's
not for sure but it gives them a good
step up with those life skills to
do something right
the skills we teach them here are going
to make them good employees wherever
they end up
that's pretty fulfilling you know that
that these guys can actually do
something out of the training that that
i've been part of so that's special
you